They say that you should set a thief to catch
a thief as no one else understands the criminal
mind better.
Perhaps the most shining example of this idiom
is Vidocq, the man who is now hailed as the
father of modern criminology.
He went from a life of crime spent either
on the run or in the prisons of France to
establishing a national detective police force
that served as the model for Scotland Yard
and others that followed it.
He employed proto-forensic techniques such
as ballistics and casting foot impressions.
When he left the force, he started his own
agency and became the world's first private
eye.
Vidocq goes against many of the tropes we
have of the stereotypical detective.
He was far from brilliant and his success
was more down to him being methodical and
persuasive.
He had a violent streak and was chiefly motivated
by money.
He made plenty of enemies in his career and,
as you are about to see, his life was filled
with almost as many failures as successes.
Early Days
Most of the information surrounding the detective's
early years comes straight from the horse's
mouth courtesy of the Memoirs of Vidocq, the
autobiography he published with the help of
a ghost-writer around 1828.
Feel free to take it with a generous helping
of salt.
Eugène François Vidocq was born in the city
of Arras, in the Pas-de-Calais department
in northern France, on July 23, 1775.
He was the third of seven children of Nicolas
Joseph François Vidocq, a prosperous baker,
and his wife, Henriette Françoise.
He was born in the house next to the one where
Maximilien Robespierre was born sixteen years
prior.
Image suggestion: The Citadel in the Place
d'Armes
The Vidocq family lived in a rough area of
Arras called the Place d'Armes and, consequently,
the young Eugène got into scraps at an early
age.
Fortunately for him, Vidocq had a large, strong
constitution and, by age eight, already bragged
about being the terror of the children in
the neighborhood.
He also took up fencing when he was young
and, by age thirteen, was prodigious with
the foil.
First Troubles with the Law
Vidocq's life of crime started as a teenager
and his first target was his own family business.
The youth worked for his father's bakery by
making deliveries around town and would dip
into the till for money to spend at the pub.
It was also at this time that he began making
the acquaintances of the city's local blackguards,
cons, and other various villains.
When his father discovered this, he began
locking the till, but the enterprising Vidocq
forged the key with the help of a blacksmith's
son.
When the senior Vidocq, again, put an end
to his son's scheme, the offspring began simply
stealing items and pawning them.
This led to his first arrest and a few days
in Baudets, the local jail.
Instead of setting him straight, this experience
convinced Vidocq to go for one big score and
then leave town.
He broke into the bakery with the help of
a friend and absconded with 2,000 francs.
He split the money in half with his accomplice
and each went their separate ways.
Life on the Streets
Early on in his life on the run, Vidocq learned
a harsh, but necessary lesson: there is always
a bigger fish.
He might have considered himself a successful
criminal, but was still naïve in the ways
of the world.
While traveling through Belgium to secure
passage on a ship, he met an amiable stranger
who took him to a house full of friendly,
beautiful women.
There, he was drugged and he woke up the next
morning on the docks, half-naked, with only
a few crowns to his name.
Vidocq was forced to take employment where
he could find it so he joined a troupe of
performers.
He was treated miserably, beaten regularly
and given scraps for food.
His appearance became so wretched that, at
one point, he was asked to pretend to be a
savage island cannibal who feasted on raw
flesh.
This prompted him to leave and he joined a
group of puppeteers, but this new gig did
not last long as he was kicked out for making
sweet eyes at his employer's wife.
From there, he hooked up with a traveling
group of peddlers led by one Father Godard.
Back Home
When opportunity arose, Vidocq returned home
to Arras where his father, eventually, forgave
him.
He enlisted in the army and joined the Bourbon
regiment where his reputation and his temper
would often lead to fights.
After six months, Vidocq had earned the nickname
"Reckless" after engaging in fifteen duels
and killing two men.
In 1792, France entered combat with Austria
in the War of the First Coalition.
Vidocq took part in several battles and was
promoted to grenadier, but deserted after
receiving a court-martial for hitting an officer.
He joined the 11th Chasseurs under a different
name and, although his desertion was discovered,
a captain interceded on his behalf and all
was forgiven.
After being shot in the leg, the 18-year-old
Vidocq returned to Arras.
From One Prison to the Next
Vidocq's years as a young adult seemed to
have been mostly divided between the prison
cell and the army.
On the rare occasions that he was free of
both, he typically engaged in romantic trysts
or felonious ventures.
He even married once, but the relationship
ended quickly.
His adventures took him to Brussels where
he presented himself as Monsieur Rousseau
since Eugène Vidocq was, once again, wanted
for desertion.
In 1795, he joined the flying army and became
a hussar captain.
He caught the eye of an elderly, widowed baroness
who bequeathed him a generous sum that enabled
Vidocq to live it up in Paris for a while.
After a few months, the money was gone and
Vidocq was back in prison.
Here, he discovered a new talent – forgery
– and, with the aid of a lover named Francine
Longuet, escaped several times, but was always
recaptured soon after.
In just five years, Vidocq had been imprisoned
in Bicêtre, Douai, Senlis, Brest, and Toulon,
not to mention once being shanghaied in Rotterdam
and having a short stint as a privateer aboard
a Dutch ship.
The Turnaround
In 1800, a 25-year-old Vidocq escaped prison
and made his way back home.
He found out that his father had died the
previous year.
He wanted to stay with his mother, but was
recognized and had to flee again.
In Rouen, he assumed the identity of a merchant
named Blondel.
He was successful for a couple of years and
planned to send for his mother before being
discovered and having to go on the run once
more.
Time and time again, Vidocq tried to start
a new life in a new city, but it seemed that
everywhere he went, his past soon caught up
with him.
In 1809, Vidocq found himself in familiar
surroundings after being arrested and sent
to the prison in Bicêtre.
Undoubtedly, he could have escaped.
He could have used a disguise, or bribed the
guards, or climbed the walls and, eventually,
Vidocq would have been a free man again.
However, he had grown weary of prison escapes
and the fleeting liberties they provided.
He offered to put his experience and reputation
to good use and become a prison informant.
A police chief named Jean Henry accepted the
deal and relocated Vidocq to La Force Prison
in Paris.
Image suggestion: La Force Prison
It didn't take long for the prisoner to prove
his worth.
Vidocq made the acquaintance of France Tormel,
a criminal who was part of a gang of prolific
robbers.
Although already imprisoned, it would not
be long before Tormel was released due to
lack of evidence or witnesses.
Vidocq managed to gain his confidence enough
that the felon revealed to him the residence
of his mistress.
Sure enough, police conducted a raid and found
enough stolen merchandise to sentence Tormel
to eight years.
Not only that, but the criminal still trusted
Vidocq and gave him enough information to
get his accomplices arrested, as well.
For twenty-one months, Vidocq plied his informant
services between the walls of the prison.
Eventually, Henry realized that he would be
more useful on the outside as he would be
able to infiltrate many criminal establishments
instead of just waiting for the criminals
to come to him.
They secured his release and made it look
like just another escape.
Vidocq Is Out
For the first time in a long while, Eugène
Vidocq could walk the streets as himself without
having to worry that the first officer who
recognized him would try to arrest him.
He wasn't completely a free man, though.
Vidocq was a secret agent in the service of
the state.
His goal was to gather information that resulted
in the prevention of crime and capture of
felons.
His first collar was a counterfeiter named
Watrin.
In his autobiography, Vidocq pointed out that
this was the beginning of a problem that dogged
him his entire time on the force and well
into his career as a private detective.
All the other officers were jealous of his
success and relished the opportunity to see
him fail.
Under the old adage of "two heads are better
than one", Vidocq brought in some help and
organized an informal unit called the Brigade
de la Sûreté (Security Brigade) to aid in
his crime-fighting.
It consisted mostly of other reformed criminals
such as himself.
Back then, France's police force was mainly
divided in two.
There was the police politique which was the
secret police that handled covert operations
and uncovered intrigues against the state.
And there was the standard, man-in-the-street
uniformed police that dealt with common crimes
like theft, murder, and fraud.
Crucially, Vidocq convinced his superiors
that his agents should avoid the uniform and,
instead, don plain clothes and even disguises
to help them infiltrate areas that were, otherwise,
off-limits to police.
The Sûreté Is Born
The group was a success.
Less than a year after it appeared, the Sûreté
officially became a unit of plainclothes detectives
under the purview of the Prefecture of Police
of Paris with Vidocq as its first chief.
Image suggestion: Napoleon
Fortunately for him, the man at the top, Napoleon,
was also a keen reorganizer of France's police
force.
He established the Prefecture of Police in
1800 and also increased the numbers and responsibilities
of the gendarmerie who, up until that point,
functioned mainly as a semi-militarized force
dispatched to keep the peace in rural areas
of the country.
Seemingly, Bonaparte approved of Vidocq's
revolutionary approach to crime-fighting and,
a year later, further expanded the Sûreté
into the state security service known as the
Sûreté Nationale.
Vidocq trained all of his agents personally.
Even when he had a few dozen men under him,
he still enjoyed dressing up like a beggar
and hitting the streets for some undercover
work.
His unit was responsible for hundreds of arrests
and reportedly decreased the crime rate in
Paris by up to 40 percent.
According to criminologist John Philip Stead,
in 1817 alone the Sûreté made 811 arrests,
including 341 thieves, 46 forgers, 14 escaped
prisoners, and 15 assassins.
1817 turned out to be a particularly fruitful
year for Vidocq because he also received a
full pardon for his past crimes from King
Louis XVIII.
Up until that point, although he was a superior
officer with the Paris police force, Vidocq
was still, technically, a wanted criminal.
The First Retirement
The following decade proved to be a more turbulent
time for the policeman, both personally and
professionally.
He married again in 1820, but his wife passed
away four years later and his mother died
shortly after.
In his professional life, Vidocq started to
lose the support of his superiors.
Jean Henry retired and the next police chief,
Marc Duplessis, was not a fan of the Sûreté.
Jules Anglès, the police prefect who obtained
a pardon for Vidocq, also had to retire after
failing to prevent the assassination of Charles
Ferdinand, Duke of Berry.
Finally, the king himself died and was succeeded
by Charles X.
Image suggestion: King Charles X
Vidocq always maintained that the antipathy
showed to him by other members of the police
force was due to envy of his success.
While there was certainly plenty of that,
there was also resentment that a criminal
would advance so high up the ranks without
facing any serious consequences for his illicit
past.
At the same time, Vidocq became quite wealthy
and famous during his career in law enforcement.
He rubbed elbows with Parisian elite like
Victor Hugo and Honoré de Balzac and made
enough money to start his own paper company.
There were unsubstantiated rumors that he
continued his criminal activities, but now
he just did it with the help of the law.
By 1827, Vidocq had had one too many confrontations
with his new boss.
After 18 years on the force, the 52-year-old
tended his resignation to Marc Duplessis.
The police chief was happy to be rid of him
although, bizarrely, he appointed as his successor
another ex-convict agent named Barthelemy
"Coco" Lacour.
A Short Return and a Second Retirement
Vidocq might have been a shrewd criminal and
a pioneering detective, but he was not a very
good businessman.
It did not take long before his company went
bankrupt but, on the bright side, the time
off allowed him to put down his memoirs.
By 1831, Duplessis was gone and the new police
prefect, Henri Gisquet, invited Vidocq back
on the force.
He was chief of the Sûreté again, but his
position was short-lived.
Perhaps it was merely a symptom of the instability
felt in France during the July Monarchy, or
maybe due to the cholera outbreak that was
ravaging the country, but people showed little
indulgence towards Vidocq and his group of
ex-convicts.
A few instances occurred in short succession
where agents of the Sûreté were accused
of acting as provocateurs against rioters
and some were even implicated in a theft.
The unit's actions became harder and harder
to justify and, by the end of 1832, Vidocq
was once again "cordially invited" to resign.
He did so by citing concern for the health
of his third wife who, by the way, was also
his cousin.
Following his departure, the Sûreté was
purged of anyone who had a criminal record,
even for minor offences.
From Spy to Private Eye
The former agents did not have to look long
for a new job.
In 1833, Vidocq founded Le Bureau des Renseignements
pour le Commerce ("Office of Information for
Businesses").
For a fee, clients could access Vidocq's database
of profiles on crooks and frauds.
Should the need arise, they could also hire
agents to conduct personal investigations
and surveillance into their interests which
often had nothing to do with business and,
instead, pertained to private matters such
as adultery or finances.
Business information bureaus already existed,
but because of the extra investigation services,
many consider Vidocq's new endeavor to constitute
the world's first private detective agency.
Once again, he predominantly hired ex-convicts,
many of them former agents of the Sûreté
since he already trained them.
If the rest of the police force had contempt
for Vidocq before, now they loathed him.
Many were not pleased with the idea of an
extrajudicial group investigating crimes for
the highest bidder.
Accusations were thrown now more than ever
before that Vidocq and his detectives operated
in a grey area of the law, at best, and did
not shy away from a few illegalities to finish
the job.
You can't argue with results, though, and
the agency flourished at first.
However, his quarrels with the true police
force led to several arrests and seizures.
The new police prefect, Gabriel Delessert,
was definitely not a fan of Vidocq and always
looked for a new chance to crush his business.
That opportunity arrived in 1842 when the
prefect ordered a massive raid on the agency
which resulted in Vidocq's arrest.
He stood accused of fraud and illegal arrest.
Image suggestion: Conciergerie
Eventually, Vidocq was free again, but not
before spending 11 months in the prison of
the Conciergerie.
When he was released, he was 67 years old
and it became pretty clear to him that his
best days were far behind him.
He spent the rest of his life mostly out of
the limelight and died in 1857.
Elementary, My Dear Vidocq
Vidocq laid the groundwork for the calling
of the detective, but we should be clear that
he was never a Sherlock Holmes-type character.
He did not fit our image of the typical brilliant
detective who gives brainy summations in a
room full of suspects and reveals how the
murderer did it while chewing on a lit pipe.
If anything, he was a more successful psychologist
than detective.
He knew how to use his appearance, his reputation,
and his attitude to get other criminals to
trust and confide in him.
Another dull, but practical ace up his sleeve
was his obsession with keeping accurate and
detailed records on all the criminals he encountered.
Vidocq often boasted of having an incredible
memory, but he knew that his agents were not
as gifted.
Early in its infancy, the Sûreté began making
index cards for the rogues of Paris, listing
their physical appearance, distinguishing
traits, prior convictions, modus operandi,
and any other information that might prove
useful.
The system was primitive, but it worked, and
it came in real handy later when Vidocq started
his private agency.
The Sûreté made use of it for decades until
it was overhauled and improved by Alphonse
Bertillon.
This being said, let's not completely detract
from the man's accomplishments as Vidocq put
his talents to good use in ways very few other
crime-fighters had done up until that point.
He's had, at least, a handful of cases that
would serve well for a Sunday afternoon crime
show.
On one occasion, Vidocq met early one morning
with a suspected thief named Hotot.
The latter looked tired, his clothes were
wet and his boots were muddy.
Clearly, this was a man who had had a busy
night.
Vidocq excused himself and went to inquire
about burglaries that happened the night before.
He arrived at a crime scene and noticed a
pair of footprints which made him think of
Hotot's muddy boots.
He had an agent fetch some plaster of Paris
and he made a cast of the prints which he
then matched to the criminal's boots.
Hotot confessed and was sent to the galley.
Image suggestion: Cap and ball pistol
Another time, Vidocq investigated the notorious
murder of Countess Isabelle d'Arcy.
Everybody assumed her husband had shot her,
but the detective relied on a primitive form
of ballistics to prove the count innocent.
He had the doctor extract the bullet from
the countess's body – something he had to
do in secret because it was highly irregular
for that time – and showed that the ball
was too large to fit in Count d'Arcy's dueling
pistol.
Instead, Vidocq matched it to the weapon of
the countess's lover who confessed.
Lunch with a Side of Murder
Image suggestion: Jean Valjean/Javert side-by-side
Eugène Vidocq might be long gone, but his
legacy lives on.
His literary friends immortalized him in their
books as Balzac based several characters on
him, chief among them the criminal mastermind
Vautrin.
In his seminal work, Les Misérables, Victor
Hugo drew inspiration for both of his main
characters, the convict Jean Valjean and the
policeman Javert, from the dual life of Vidocq.
The detective himself left behind quite a
complimentary account of his exploits in the
form of his memoirs.
But perhaps no other tribute is more fitting
than the Vidocq Society.
Back in September 1990, three criminal experts
met for lunch.
William Fleisher was a retired Philadelphia
police officer and FBI agent, Frank Bender
was a forensic sculptor, and Richard Walter
was a criminal psychologist.
They started talking shop and the discussion,
eventually, turned to cold cases.
The three men realized that their knowledge
and experience could prove to be an asset
to a detective who is stuck looking for that
one little clue that could lead to a break
in the case.
Not only that, but they knew plenty of other
people who could also lend their expertise.
Thus, the Vidocq Society was born.
How It Works
The organization meets once a month at the
Union League of Philadelphia.
It has 82 permanent members (one for each
year that Vidocq lived), although many others
have joined as Special members by invitation
only.
They include forensic scientists, law enforcement
officers, prosecutors, profilers, medical
examiners, and psychologists.
Seldom will you find more experts on crime
gathered under the same roof.
The members have lunch and listen to an investigator
who is there to present a murder case.
He is stumped.
He is out of leads and the trail has gone
cold for years.
He is hoping that the people there might have
some extra insight.
Members of the Vidocq Society offer guidance
and advice and, in certain cases, even travel
to the officer's jurisdiction to take a more
hands-on approach with the investigation.
Over the years, the society has concentrated
its efforts on cold cases from small or underfunded
police precincts where its efforts would have
the largest impact.
The Legacy Continued
The society first tasted success in March
of 1991.
The family of a murder victim named Huey Cox
from Little Rock, Arkansas, believed that
the man charged with the crime was innocent.
Vidocqians agreed.
Two of them provided expert testimony at the
trial and the case was dismissed.
Almost 30 years have passed since then.
The Vidocq Society helped solve cases like
the Arizona Canal Murders and family annihilator
John List.
The group stresses that it doesn't want fame
or glory and, indeed, often there is none.
The society laments that not enough investigators
are actually aware of their services and would
like a bit more attention if only so that
it can work more cases and continue the detective
legacy
of Eugène Vidocq.